criminal justice the process by which
you are arrested charged and eventually
go before a jury who render their
verdict we find the defendant Robert
Brooks not guilty we find Randall Bailey
guilty we find the defendant not guilty
have you reached the wording guilty or
not guilty
that is just objectively charming
although all these years later I still
can't believe those penguins wrongfully
convicted the Central Park five now
whenever whenever we talk whenever we
talk about criminal justice reform we
tend to just talk about policing public
defenders judges and prisons and skip
over a crucial element there prosecutors
the attorneys who work for the federal
state and local government and bring
cases to trial there are roughly 2,500
DA's offices all around the country and
they have a surprising amount of
influence at almost every single stage
of the criminal justice system because
prosecutors decide whether you get
charged and what you get charged with
and therefore heavily influenced what
kind of sentence you could face and you
you sort of know deep down how important
they are because of a little phrase that
crops up constantly
in local news crime stories ultimately
it'll be prosecutors who decide whether
charges will be filed prosecutors will
decide whether to file criminal charges
prosecutors will decide what happens
next prosecutors will decide exactly
prosecutors will decide it's one of
those three word phrases that you hear
so often you don't even think about what
it means anymore like User Agreement
update or some restrictions apply or
Tyler Perry presents you know at this
point I'm just going to assume that he
presents everything it's safer that way
I technically think he presents this
show I wouldn't be completely surprised
about that
I look we tend not to think about that
power very much except when there is a
high-profile controversy concerning
prosecutors failure to exercise it as
has happened in numerous police
shootings of unarmed black men or when
Manhattan da saw Vance declined to
prosecute Harvey Weinstein in 2015
citing insufficient evidence despite
police officials insisting that they had
plenty of evidence including Exhibit A
his face but but it but it is worth
talking about what happens when
prosecutors do decide to exercise that
power because while many try to do their
jobs honorably that power can be misused
or amplified the inequities inherent in
the system and let's start with a truly
incredible fact here the vast majority
of the time your fate is not decided by
a judge or a jury of your peers because
nearly 95 percent of the cases
prosecutors decide to bring end up with
the defendant pleading guilty now what
that means is no trial no innocent until
proven guilty just a prosecutor striking
a deal behind closed doors and many
judges are resigned to that fact because
at least plea bargains keep the system
moving the system would collapse if
every case that was filed in the
criminal justice system were to be set
for trial the system would just entirely
collapse exactly it's an inadequate
system that only functions if people
constantly give up it's built on the
exact same model as AT&T x' customer
service hotline that's right AT&T new
owners of HBO longtime owners of an
unforgivably dog customer service
hotline
if somebody pleads guilty they they must
have done it that's not necessarily the
case in Houston testing of samples in
drug cases have exonerated 133 people
since 2014 and those people had pled
guilty in every single case which is
messed up the only people who should be
claiming to have used drugs when they
happen to awkward teenagers at high
school parties oh I'm totally a wieder
I'm into all the weeds I'm stoning right
now that's how potted I am so so why do
innocent people plead guilty what
prosecutors will often offer a deal
while threatening that if you go to
trial they will stack charges against
you and pursue a much harsher sentence
it's something commonly referred to as a
trial penalty just listen to Rodney
Roberts he was accused of a sexual
assault the DNA evidence later proved he
did not commit and I'll let him explain
what he took a deal when I finally got
to the court this attorney he came in
and told me that the prosecutor office
had a plea agreement from it and like
plea agreement even do it you know I
pled not guilty I'm innocent
he was like this urgent he was this
pressure and he was like if you don't
take this deal the only offer your two
years you're home in two years and if
not you know they're gonna take it off
to trial and a judge is ready to give
you a life sentence if you get found
guilty and I think you're gonna get
found guilty and this is my attorney
telling me it's the one person I had to
dead out me so I thought that to get
home to my son
they're my family and established in my
life that the best thing I could do for
myself was to plead guilty and fight it
once I got home and as crazy as it
sounds to hear that it kind of makes
sense two years in prison is terrible
but a life sentence is absolutely
terrifying the only way that makes sense
were defendant to risk that is if
they're a gerbil because two years in
life are basically the same thing to
those litters
but but but let's say you are one of the
five percent of people who risk going to
trial prosecutors still have lots of
ways to try and gain an advantage for
instance prosecutors are not allowed to
discriminate by race during jury
selection and if it's suspected that
they are the Supreme Court has said that
they could be required to provide race
neutral explanations for striking tours
which sounds like a good rule but it has
been laughably easy for them to get
around because judges will accept just
about any reason in Texas a training
document for prosecutors even
conveniently listed examples of
race-neutral reasons that judges had
accepted including having a 1970s hairdo
being a very pretty girl who might be
attracted to the defendant or the
defense counsel wearing a Malcolm X hat
agreeing with the OJ Simpson verdict
being a male wearing earrings in both
ears and my personal favorites for
wearing a bad boys club jacket pink hat
and snakeskin belts which is just
insulting because that look does not
make you untrustworthy it makes you
awesome I like the way I look at
guarantee perhaps the area where
prosecutors can exert the most influence
concerns evidence because they control
the case files things like police
reports witness information and physical
evidence and while they are required to
hand over anything that is exculpatory
or that might be useful in your defense
in some states including New York they
can do that at the very last minute
something incredible happens on the day
of trial certainly a case file that for
a year was this thick suddenly now
becomes this thick and so in our most
serious cases in the cases where we have
climbed to are looking at incredible
amounts of potential jail time even life
in jail this is what we are given when
DA's answer ready for trial and the
reality is is that in Manhattan too
often it is trial by ambush it's true
and they can then have to argue a case
without having read all the important
material it's basically a much higher
stakes version of a kid giving a
presentation in English class without
having read the book in conclusion
whether Heights the heights are watering
but by the end the heights rather much
more than they weathered at the
beginning of the book thank you for your
time just a quick but important message
for English teachers no one has ever
read a single book you have ever
assigned it has never happened not once
and look sometimes defense attorneys may
not be given exculpatory evidence at all
in fact among exoneration cases around
1/4 of them involve prosecutors
concealing its culprit ory evidence and
that is because prosecutors typically
get to decide whether something is
relevant to the defense which seems
inherently flawed
you can't just count on an adversary to
voluntarily expose all of their
weaknesses in Star Wars the rebels had
to steal the Death Star plans the Empire
didn't just email it to them with a
subject line for word gigantic stupid
weak spot parentheses very dumb go to
town and when prosecutors do withhold
evidence there is very little
accountability for them take Michael
Morton like in 1987 he was wrongfully
convicted of his wife's murder after the
prosecutor in that case withheld crucial
pieces of exculpatory evidence now the
good news is that prosecutor Ken
Anderson was held to account for that
misconduct the bad news is there was a
slight discrepancy between the two men's
sentences Morton served nearly 25 years
in prison
8900 95 days and now the sentence for
the prosecutor just 10 days in jail for
contempt of court 10 days and he served
less than half that although before you
get too mad he did also have to pay a
$500 fine which which isn't really the
penalty you'd expect for wiping out 25
years of someone's life it's close to
what you'd expect for a
cantaloupe at Whole Foods 10 days for
the public indecency $500 for the
cantaloupe
and to make it to make it even worse
Anderson is actually the only prosecutor
to ever serve any time for misconduct
resulting in a wrongful conviction ever
because the truth is prosecutors rarely
face any sort of consequences for
misconduct state bars are supposed to
hold them accountable but a study of
five states found that in 660 cases
where courts had confirmed prosecutorial
misconduct the number of prosecutors
disciplined in those cases was one and
that lack of accountability can fuel a
dangerous culture where winds are
already prioritized to a disturbing
degree in fact in one DA's office in
Colorado
prosecutors were paid bonuses for
achieving a high conviction rate and in
Texas a DA rewarded convictions in
misdemeanor cases with a prize that they
called the trial dog award and let me
just say as the proud proud owner of
nine trial dogs my award goes to this
one please don't die please please don't
die I can't how important it is for you
to hang in there and and and there was
there was the notoriously aggressive
office also of New Orleans DA Harry
Connick senior who is yes Harry Connick
Jr's dad in fact here they are on Harry
jr. short-lived talk show singing a
weirdly inappropriate Joette just well
the
[Music]
[Applause]
Harry's wild about me the heavenly
places of his kisses
yeah now if you didn't see any problem
with that he's just a fun experiment for
you to try at home call your own father
right now
tell him that the heavenly bliss is of
his kisses fill you with ecstasy and
just see how that goes my prediction is
your next fishing trip is going to be
extra quiet but during his time as New
Orleans da lots of people were wild
about Harry Connick senior because his
office was famously ruthless Harry
Connick was tough on crime he was very
aggressive and he wanted to block him
all up forever conics lead prosecutor
was Jim Williams Jim took great pride in
his numerous death penalty convictions
he even kept a miniature electric chair
on his desk Jim was regarded as one of
the most aggressive prosecutors in the
District Attorney's Office he described
sliding up behind defendants in the
courtroom and buzzing in their ears to
mimic the the buzz of electricity holy
that is just not okay although
there was also literally no scenario in
which sliding up behind someone in
saying buzz in their ear is acceptable
not even if you are Neil Armstrong on
the moon and you need to get Buzz
Aldrin's attention hey buzz buzz buzz
buzz we're on the moon buzz buzz buzz
buzz are you mad I was first buzz buzz
but but that office is win at all costs
culture resulted in some serious
mistakes as it turns out fully a quarter
of the men sentenced to death during
conics tenure had their convictions
overturned because of improperly
withheld evidence and remember that
little electric chair when the
prosecutors had on his desk here's a fun
fact in the photo of Jim Williams with
the electric chair of the five faces
visible all of them were released from
death row yep
the thing he kept as a token of his
success is now a monument to poor
decision-making it is the prosecutorial
equivalent of Cuba Gooding jr. zaask er
and look if you want to see why did that
joke upset you more than anything else
tonight you have got to be consistent
you've got to be you might care about
Cuba you care about him too much in this
context and look if you want to see all
the problems that I've described tonight
in action just take a look at the case
of Glen Ford who was on death row for 30
years after being wrongfully convicted
now the prosecutor on his case Marty
Stroud says that he got caught up in an
aggressive hard-charging culture and
admits to among other things
deliberately excluding African American
jurors and overlooking evidence that
would have cleared Glen Ford and what
happened clearly still haunts him I
ended up without anybody else's help
putting a man on death row who didn't
belong there I mean at the end of the
day beginning in middle whatever you
want to call it I did something that was
very very bad yeah it was it was very
very very bad in fact the problem is
that while he is clearly remorseful in
terms of accountability there were no
professional sanctions for his actions
in fact the acting da after Ford was
released Dale Cox doesn't even believe
that Stroud should have apologized did
mr. Ford get justice in this case I
think he has
gotten delayed justice the system did
not fail mr. Ford it did not it did not
in fact the system you see that because
he's not on death row and that's how I
can say it getting out of prison after
30 years is justice well it's better
than dying there and it's better than
being executed yeah I guess that's true
but listen to how low he's setting the
bar they're better than being executed
or dying in prison by that measure
anything succeeds Taco Bell
better than being executed or dying in
prison although when you think about it
is it is it definitely between 2010 and
2014 that man's office was responsible
for sending more prisoners to death row
than anywhere else in the country and if
you think the Glen Ford debacle may have
made him more cautious you would be
wrong I think society should be
employing the death penalty more rather
than less but there have been ten other
inmates on death row in Louisiana who
have been exonerated clearly the system
is not flawless
are you sure that you've gotten a right
all the time I'm reasonably confident
that that I've gotten it right
oh you're reasonably confident are you
that does not seem like it should be the
standard to send someone to death row I
was reasonably confident I could pull
off bangs I was wrong about that
and if someone's life depended on it I
might have given it a little more
thought and look at this point you may
well be wondering how can we fix some of
what we've seen tonight well clearly
permanent legislative fixes are badly
needed from requiring greater
transparency from prosecutors about
sharing evidence through so-called
open file laws to ideally establishing
independent commissions to investigate
misconduct but depending on where you
live there may actually be a more direct
way for you to effect change because
DA's are usually elected it's something
you might sometimes forget until you see
aggressive campaign attack ads like this
one which ends in a bizarre turn of
phrase this is how many child molesters
the Calcasieu Parish do
he has prosecuted as lead counsel
how many murders how many rapes Roberts
meanwhile our sheriff reports crime is
on the rise and Calcasieu Parish Steve
Street for District Attorney
he'll try harder and a lot more but he
would try a harder and a lot more often
that's a pretty weak promise Steve the
was your opponent's Logan Nathan
Hamilton justice on Mondays and
Wednesdays unless something comes up
well it seems like it's gonna be a whole
thing look the facts prosecutors are
elected means that you can change them
the problem is around 85% of prosecutors
actually run unopposed in both primary
and general elections it's gotten so bad
that in one County in Washington state
their prosecutor had run for ten terms
without any opposition so four years ago
in frustration someone ran ran their dog
against him I know I know what you're
thinking I'll great another white dog
prosecutor and I'm not saying you're
wrong but let's go one step at a time
here look clearly we need more
reform-minded DA's to run because thanks
to the extreme breadth of power they
have that could actually be a backdoor
way to effect change on a whole host of
issues from fail to the misuse of
forensic science to the enforcement of
marijuana laws and maybe you are one of
the lucky ones here maybe your local DA
is great
or maybe they're a win obsessed
whose heavenly Bliss's of their kisses
fill their adults songs with ecstasy or
maybe a live in Washington State over
the past four years your district
attorney has been this dog and
you didn't even realize it because can
you honestly say with a hundred percent
certainty that your district attorney is
not a dog you probably can't and that's
kind of the problem here most people
know as much about their local DA as
they know about their local Cheesecake
Factory manager chances are you don't
know who they are and if you do it's
probably because something truly
terrible has happened
but the truth is like the Cheesecake
Factory
prosecutors have the ability to ruin
lives in a second so so we need to find
out who our DA's are and get a sense of
the policies and priorities that they're
carrying out where we live because if we
do not decide ourselves what we want the
criminal justice system to look like
deep down you know who will exactly they
will